this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much mike for that
resounding vote of confidence
um and uh yeah so so today i'm going to
to talk to you about kind of my rna
centric
view of of how plants respond
to to stress or changes in their
environment
um and so i guess when most of us think
about um
sorry when most of us think about rna in
terms of
stress responses we really think of
their steady state levels where we're
imagining
that these rnas or the abundance of
these rnas are really a proxy for
for the protein so of course you have
changes in the environment eliciting
some gene to produce an rna
that is in producing a protein and then
that is the response that we're really
thinking about
and so rna is really just this
intermediate this this messenger
but while
a lot of very interesting biology and
molecular mechanisms have
come about from this perspective i would
argue that there are a number of
ways in which rnas act that don't depend
on
producing a protein so there are the
long encoding rnas and there are the
small non-coding rnas
and while many of them do kind of
interfere
or regulate the production of a protein
many of them can elicit a response in
their own rights without ever
producing or regulating protein
production or translation
and so some of the rna mediated
responses
that i'm interested in i i have listed
here and i'm going to talk about several
of them today
but the first one is going to focus on
as mike mentioned the long encoding rna
class of rnas
for which we know relatively little in
all of eukaryotes really
okay what are long encoding rnas well
longer cutting rnas are these uh
these transcripts that are greater than
200 nucleotides
for which we have little evidence of
protein synthesis
so no strong open reading frame
and these transcripts can arise really
from anywhere in the genome
which means they can be transcribed from
energetic space between two other genes
but they can also be transcribed in the
anti-sense direction overlapping
a known gene or actually even
intronically
within a known protein-coding gene for
instance
and most of these transcripts most of
these link rnas are thought to be pulp 2
transcribed
so they're going to have a five prime
cap and a poly a tail and this is
important when it comes to identifying
and using rna sequencing data
because we because since they look just
like mrnas and
we're capturing mrnas we're going after
mrnas primarily in our rna sequencing
data that means we can
pull out or identify link rnas from
these data as well
link rnas typically display poor
sequence conservation and this
really i think is one of the main
hindrances in terms of identifying leak
rnas and
close relatives of model systems in
which we've identified link rnas
to begin with so poor sequence
conservation and i'll talk about
this a little bit more later as well
in terms of function we know that link
rnas are we often think of link rnas
primarily in their role as a
transcriptional regulator so link rnas
are often
regulating the transcription of genes
either in cysts or in trans
we know that link rnas can also regulate
production of our protein synthesis
through
modulating how micrornas are binding to
mrnas
lincrnase through sequence
complementarity can actually recruit
away
micrornas from their intended target and
allow for protein synthesis to occur
rnas also are commonly known as
modifiers of the epigenetic state
particularly of the chromatin
around the locus that they're being
transcribed from
and this usually occurs through the
recruitment of the polycomb
repressor complex prc2 which then comes
in
and lays down chromatin marks
and lastly link rnas are known to
act as these scaffolds these rna
scaffolds that
recruit proteins that wouldn't normally
interact
together into a single complex that then
has
either enzymatic or some kind of
molecular function
and one an important example of this is
the telomerase rna
which actually um which is an rna i
studied as a
as a graduate student in dorothy's lab
and this already brings together
a whole suite of proteins that never
that don't physically interact
directly but together through this
scaffold rna they come together and they
maintain chromosomes
in eukaryotes i should
mention here that only a few link rnas
have been functionally characterized in
plants
particularly in arabidopsis where most
of our
knowledge about london encoding rnas
comes from
and this is in stark contrast to the
hundreds of incarnates that have been
functionally annotated
in mammals so here i'm just listing a
few
of the annotated link rnas again most of
these are coming from arabidopsis but
it's it's a
very uh small number and i'd like to
unpack
why why that is or why i think that that
is
and to describe that sort of describe
this
disparity i'm showing you a phylogeny
representing
um most uh angiosperms so uh eugene cots
here some
a couple asteroids and some monocots
along with what we call these more basal
species
uh humans and mice and if we just look
at the number of link rnas that have
been published for each of these species
we see that there are over a hundred
thousand link rnas have been identified
um annotated in humans and mice each
um compared to roughly about 6 000 or so
link rnas that have been published in
arabidopsis
and i would argue that this disparity
arises from the millions of dollars that
went into the human
and mouse on code projects that really
performed an enviable and exhaustive
annotation of all the functional
elements of these two
genomes where link rnas have been
identified in plants
different criteria and ex and different
experimental evidence
were used in their identification for
instance in arabidopsis eliana most of
the link rnas
that we have annotated in that genome
or actually identified using tiling
array experiments
and in contrast the link rna is
identified in some of these other
species like corn for instance were
identified using rna sequencing data
and on top of the different kind of
technologies that were used to identify
these link rnas
different criteria or filtering metrics
were used to
determine or to infer whether or not the
transcript was a link rna
so there's really kind of been this grab
bag approach hodgepodge approach
to identifying leak rnas across the
plant lineage
what we want to do is utilize what we
are in the process of doing i should say
is to utilize the available rna
sequencing data that's available
across the plant's lineage that really
i would argue brings some level of
parity
to between plants and mammals where we
have
a huge amount of rna sequencing data
present for arabinopsis
and corn and a really i would say a
decent amount to each of these other
species
that allows for an exhaustive curation
effort without
the i would say millions of dollars that
went into the
human and mouse on code projects so we
want to identify link rnas
from these rna sequencing data as i
mentioned um
we can identify lync rnas most of them
because they look
just like mrnas in terms of rna-seq
library preparation
so these rna sequencing data are a
perfect resource
and we are going through and we're in
the process of
comprehensively analyzing and
identifying link rnas
from these rna sequencing data and today
i'm going to talk a little bit about our
work
just a little snapshot of some of our
work in the brassicace lineage
now just to orient you on for those of
you who aren't familiar
with brassy casey obviously we have the
model system around obstacleanna
um here in this system in this family we
decided to
go after long encoding rnas and three
other species
to help us develop a better comparative
system
one of those species is the uh
it's camelina sativa which is known as a
plant with high quality
oil in its seeds as well as brassica
arapa which we're all quite familiar
with
uh um and you trim our sausage and air
which is a salt
uh salt tolerant species come from the
family
there's a decent amount of rna
sequencing data for each of these
species obviously
office is taliana has the most 16 000
unique sras
we processed all of these rna sequencing
data through
a couple of computational workflows that
we developed
one is called rmta which is used to
actually process all of these rd
sequencing data
in high throughput in a distributed
workflow
or a distributed manner so that we can
essentially just
start a job and walk away and all of our
our sequencing data is
processed and then we took all the
processed rna sequencing data all the
transcripts that we identified
ran them through our link rna
identification pipeline evolink
which not only identifies link rnas but
also assesses the degree to which link
rnas are conserved across a particular
lineage
and then we kind of we we identified
link rnas
we initially identify about 21 000 lung
encoding rnas and arabidopsistaliana
these are supplementing the previous
data sets or the previous annotation
for arabidopsis then we also identify a
similar or greater number in each of the
other species
now one of the things that we did on top
of
just merely identifying these link rnas
and saying
that each of these transcripts are
appear to be non-coding
as we applied some additional
hierarchical
filters that have been uh applied in
mammalian systems
to get at a short list of more high
confidence long encoding rnas
and we can talk about what each of these
filters is afterwards if anybody's
interested in
getting the weeds but in the end we we
get
this list of about 10 000 arabidopsis
lunging coding rnas
and i should emphasize here that about
1900 of these link rnas
overlap or coin coincide with previously
identified incarnates
uh identified in arabinopsis using
tiling array
technologies okay so now that we have
link rnas we've identified them what do
we do now because
we're not just doing this for the sake
of identifying novel transcripts we'd
really like to get down to
uh some kind of function and to
identify or or to infer leak rna
function we're taking advantage of
the comparative framework that we've set
up in brassicace and that we're applying
to each of the major plant lineages that
were
in which we're identifying like rnas and
we're using these comparative frameworks
to address two questions first of which
is
should i care should i is this
transcript functional
and the second is where do i start
looking for a function
and to get at if we believe a transcript
is functional
we're using three different metrics uh
we're looking at sequence conservation
structural conservation and tissue level
transcriptome
conservation and because we have four
species
in which we've identified link rnas and
we can compare between each of these
species
when we do pairwise comparisons looking
at each of these three metrics
we get essentially a set of leak rnas
for which
we have high confidence that they're
sequence conserved they're structurally
concerned
and they appear to be conserved at the
transcriptomic level
and then we take those the the
list of link rnas and we ask our second
question
which is where do we start looking for
function we have this short list of link
rnas what do we do now
and we get at uh we infer function
based on associative techniques uh for
instance
we're using transcriptomic killed by
association like uh
gene co-expression networks uh we're
looking to see if any of our link rnas
share domains with known
functionally described link rnas it's a
very short list right now that we
believe as we develop this so that'll
that will be
an uh more promising way of getting a
function
and then we're also just asking are any
of these link rnas transcriptionally
responsive
to changes in the environment so we have
all of these uh stress
experiments that are publicly available
that the community has already
performed we're asking are any of these
link rnas
found to be responsive in these
experiments
and then again we perform the same kind
of pairwise comparisons
do we see a link rna from species one
say arabidopsis that is not only a
sequence concerned but also appears to
be
uh co-expressed with the same types of
genes
in both species the same
stress-responsive genes and
species and in the end what we get is
this
annotated table of all the link rnas
we've identified in each of these
species
and the degree to which they're
conserved the degree to which they're
stress responsive
or the degree to which they're involved
in different developmental processes
based on these analyses
and we're using these as i said we're
using these approaches now
in the breast casey now that we have
these link rna data sets from multiple
species
we we really we can't do this if we we
couldn't do this if we just have leaked
rnas from arabidopsis for instance
because we would have nothing to compare
against
um comparing between arabidopsis and
corn for instance is too far of an
evolutionary distance link rnas are just
so poorly conserved
that we can't make those types of
analyses or comparisons
okay so first we we just look at
sequence conservation and what i'm
showing here is is from
arabidopsistaliana perspective the
degree to which a link rna
can be traced back through evolutionary
time
back to the base of brassy casey and
you'll notice straight off that roughly
43 or 44 percent of arabidopsis link
rnas
are restricted to the arabidopsis genus
based on sequence conservation
in contrast to about three percent of
protein getting genes that are
restricted to the around valve's
genus you can compare this to what we
see
um when we compare between robin off
staliana
and lineage two represented here by
brassica rappa
shrinkiella and eutrima we see about 27
of the arabidopsis link rnas are
conserved to this
evolutionary time point and then only
one percent roughly one percent is
conserved based on sequence similarity
to uh terrania haslariana
which is a member of cleomacey which is
the sister family
of brassy casey within the brassicailys
again contrasting this with the sequence
conservation we see at the protein level
or at the within protein coding genes
roughly 43 of protein-cutting genes can
be identified
in between arabidopsis and terrania
hascillariata
so take homes from this about 30
of the arabidopsis planting rnas we
identified can be traced
to um to node four here the coalescence
point
between arabidopsis and brassica or
eutrema
whereas 91 percent of arabidopsis
protein cutting genes can be traced
to that similar time we can also use
these analyses to determine if
our sets of link rnas are conserved as
link rnas and other species
so here i'm showing or i just want to
focus on
node 4 here again the coalescence point
between arabidopsis eliana and brassica
rappa or utrima
and about i would say more than half of
the linked rnas that are conserved at
the sequence level
between lineage one here and lineage two
are conserved as a long encoding rna
and then a large fraction are conserved
at the sequence level
to genomic elements for which we have no
annotation at all
and then a very small subsets are
conserved
as protein-coding genes are annotated as
protein-coding genes in those species
here in these two species and so
these this subsets of link rnas that are
conserved as an mrna
and a close relative these could either
be evidence of pseudogenization
where we're now looking at a link rna
that's that's undergone a
pseudogenization event
it's no longer protein coding or
it could be misannotation of the link
rna
in arabidopsis and
without going into too much detail uh
we're we're very happy that we see
very few link rnas
annotated as our sharing sequence
similarity with protein coding genes and
other
other species
so to summarize or i take home from this
this
comparative approach these roughly
three 4 thousand link rnas that we've
identified to be conserved between
brassica rapa utrema and
arabinositaliana
are promising candidates for functional
analysis promising candidates for which
we can
attempt to infer function based on these
associative
techniques i told you about however
this approach the sequence based
homology approach is going to miss link
rnas that are under
different evolutionary constraints and i
want to unpack that a little bit more
i really think that this aspect is is
really interesting
so here i'm showing you kind of an
alignment a cartoon of an alignment
between a a region of a genome in
species a
for which we've annotated a longer
cutting rna in a
centennic region of uh of a genome
in species b by centennic i mean the
protein coding genes
present in that in these two genomes are
collinear they share similarity sequence
similarity
and arrangement and if we're just going
based on a genomic perspective
in the absence of sequence conservation
at this particular locus we would say
that there's no link rna in species b
however we know based on work in
arabidopsis from martin crespi's group
and others
that some leak rnas don't need uh
sequence they function in a sequence
independent manner
it's the act of transcription that's
important
and now that we have uh link rnas that
we've identified in each of these
different species we can go through and
we can ask
if a transcript if a long encoding rna
transcript is arising from a locus
a centennic locus for which we have very
little sequence similarity
and um i'm calling these these types of
link rnas uh transcriptional synthelons
because they're arising from
synthetic space but they share very
little sequence similarity
and again this is only really possible
because we have this comparative
transcriptomic system
uh where we have link rnas identified in
each of these species
within a relative close evolutionary
time frame
and just to again we're looking at uh
the link rnas for which we were able to
identify transcriptional synthelogs
and just to take them here is that we
were able to identify an additional 3300
link rnas
that are not conserved at the sequence
level
between arabidopsis eliana and brassica
rappa but appear to be conserved
at the transcriptional level that is
they're conserved in the same genomic
space
they share symphony but they
uh share very little sequence similarity
just to give you uh uh
an example of what i'm trying to talk
about here
uh here's a koji screenshot of
chromosome four from arabidopsis daliana
and chromosome one of brassica rappa
these pink blocks are meant to indicate
syntony uh between the um
the two genomic elements and in the
wrapping of celiana we have a long
encoding rna originating
from this region right here in between
these two genes
we have a longer encoding rna
and brassica rapa originating
within this androgenic space adjacent to
this protein coding gene if we align
those two
link rnas we sh we see very little
sequence similarity however these two
long encoding rnas are transcribed under
similar conditions
and transcribed in a similar orientation
to
the the protein coding gene uh to which
they're adjacent and that we're using to
kind of anchor
the the sentiment and so this
transcriptional conservation
um supports a hypothesis of
sequence independent function and let me
describe
a scenario in which you don't need
sequence conservation or sequence at all
to be functional and this is to do this
to describe the scenario
i need to describe a little bit about
what we're doing with our associative
techniques where we're using
um gene code expression networks to
cluster uh genes with similar expression
profiles across different experimental
data
sets here i'm showing you three
different
stresses and these are time series
experiments
colds heat and wounded leaf tissue
relative to control and here you see a
module of genes with similar expression
profiles that are all induced under heat
so these would just these are most
likely genes that
are just constitutively turned on during
heat
we have in this module we have 940 genes
157 which are long encoding rnas
in this bottom module we have 250 genes
that get
turned on early on during a wounding
in leaf tissue two of which are long
encoding rnas
we would go through and we would say
these link rnas
in each of these settings are responsive
to
heat or responsive to wounding and then
we would go through
further and try to determine which of
these
to try and infer a little bit more
contextual basis for what the link rna
functions might be
and so for these two link rnas here in
the wounding module
we can ask if these link rnas are
co-expressed
with the genes directly adjacent to them
in genomic space so we're asking if
linc rnas are clustering with mrnas in
this context so in these experiments
these uh
stress experiments we got 275 long
encoding rnas and we're co-clustering
with the adjacent genes either on the
five prime or three prime ends
and one of these wounding
associated lung encoding rnas is
actually in a tail to tail
orientation with a wounding related
protein coating gene
and this lung encoding rna appears to be
transcriptionally conserved in brassica
rapa
but there's no uh sequence conservation
at this between these two link rnas and
we know based on
as i said based on other work
potentially uh sorry specifically
uh work done on this uh cold
responsively garnier svalka
that it isn't actually the the sequence
similarity it isn't the sequence
that's important for function here it's
actually paul ii transcription occurring
and blocking transcription of this
adjacent gene that's helping to
provide function for for the link rna so
these analyses provide some kind of
they allow us to make functional
hypotheses that we can then go in
and test and develop
to summarize this section i've only
given you a small kind of snippets of an
interesting comparative analysis that
we've done for these link rnas
um in uh brassy casey but some take
homes of our findings
we've we're attempting to to bring
parity
uh in terms of lincoln annotation within
the plant lineage relative to
the vertebrate lineage and we
starting but to do that we've identified
link rnas before
breast casey we've developed a short
list of link rnas that are conserved
either at the sequence level or at the
transcriptional level
that appear to be stress responsive for
which we can
infer some type of regulatory function
or capacity and interestingly
a few that we found to be
containing small open reading frames
that appear to be highly conserved
and open reading frames about 30 amino
acids or so
that are highly conserved concerns
across
the prosta casey or across the plant
lineage for which we
would really like to and understand what
they're doing
um during this process we've developed
some additional
metrics to filter out various
transcriptional artifacts to get this
high
confidence belt regarding annotation and
we believe that with these smaller
comparative
systems we can infer function for link
rnas based on
functional characterization and in close
relatives
and of course hope we hope to move on to
functional analyses
ourselves in the near future so now i'd
like to
talk about so now i've told you about a
whole class of rnas that
for which we we have relatively little
information
um and i'd like to talk about a class of
rna modifications for which we also
have relatively little information we
know that they're important
but we don't know much about what
they're doing and this of course are the
little yellow dots or circles that i've
added onto these
rnas these example rnas these are the
the epi transcriptome
that uh mike mentioned what's the fb
transcriptome
uh well we've known for probably
40 years or so that trnas and ribosome
rnas are
highly modified often when you see the
canonical trna structure you see it's
uh just like so but what the biology
textbooks don't tell you is that they're
they're frequently modified chemically
modified and in fact
there's over 92 unique chemical
modifications that occur on
trnas alone
these modifications are mostly methyl
groups here i'm showing you two of the
most common
uh modifications insects methyl
adenosine
is this methyl group uh being chemically
bound
to this amine here on the adenosine
base here is the methyl group
being bound to cytosine to give you
three methyl cytosine
there are other types of modifications
other groups but most of them are going
to be methyl groups
these modifications occur really
or can occur throughout the entire
transcript but certain modifications
based on what we know right now seem to
um
occur within specific subregions of the
transcript
for instance m6a appears to be
predominantly deposited within the three
prime etr
of mrnas and this region specific
deposition
seems to be associated with stabilizing
the transcript and allowing for
enhanced translation to occur
whereas in appears to be deposited
within the coding sequence
of transcripts and that deposition tends
to be associated with
uh degradation of the rna now
all i i'm showing you imarni's here but
modifications
as i've mentioned up here modifications
occur on all classes of rnas
so they don't just occur on mrnas or
trnas or
ribosomal rnas but they also are
deposited on leak rnas
and small rnas micrornas and
these modifications occur on all bases
and they're
they're highly ubiquitous and
we know relatively little about what
they're doing
let's talk about what we do know uh
about these modifications
and i should preface that by saying most
of what we know
comes from studies on m6a now m6a
and m3c and
are found on roughly one percent uh
each are found on roughly one percent of
mrnas
in any given cell at any given time
and we know that m6a is a very ancient
modification we know that because the
methyl transferases
associated with reading that mark and
depositing
and erasing that mark are conserved
across all three domains of life
so highly conserved modification we also
know that
m6a is differentially deposited
in terms of tissue stress or even
location within a transcript
i told you that m6a was predominantly
deposited during or within the three
prime etr
but if you look at a specific transcript
level you start to see
enrichment in other locations across the
transcript
and again where that mark is being
deposited can have
impacts on mrna stability and
function as i say here these
modifications influence
protein binding they influence stability
and they influence
translation efficiency and
in terms of biology these marks are we
know that these marks
specifically m6a is critical for proper
developments
in plants um here i'm showing you a
graphical abstract
where uh from a few years ago where the
authors showed that loss of the core and
6a methyl transferase
leads to improper shoe typical meristem
expansion
um and this is not kind of a result of
systemic loss of m6a marks
but it's actually the result of loss of
a few marks on a few
marks on a few specific transcripts that
leads to this improper
expansion so m6a is is incredibly
important
um we know this not only in arabidopsis
but we also know this from work done
in humans and mice but
m6a is just one of over 100
modifications
of which only a few have been examined
really in all eukaryotes so we know
relatively little
about the epi transcriptome uh in
particular we know we know little about
when and where these marks
are applied and the impact that they're
having
on the transcripts that they modify
and in terms of a evolutionary context
for these modifications
we know little about how
these marks are conserved and whether
the sequences
the motifs that they are applied to
are conserved across the plant lineage
and again we
don't know much about whether
modifications are conserved between
orthologs
across a lineage or if these
modifications
influence gene evolution
and that these modifications impact rnas
in similar ways across species
really we would have very little
information on a
comparative perspective to
address this gap in our knowledge
the lab or my lab has really two
projects ongoing
one is a collaborative project with dr
brian gregory
from university of pennsylvania dr eric
lyons from university of arizona and dr
rebecca murphy from centenary college
of louisiana and this project is is
taking a high-throughput approach
um utilizing publicly available iron
sequencing data
um to identify and characterize the epi
transcriptome
across the plant lineage this is the the
source of a tr attack
that was recently awarded and then the
second project is
uh taking a very a much narrower view
and a much
more fine scale view of looking at
modifications
within nebraska casey and how those
modifications are influencing plant
stress responses
i'm going to talk to you very briefly
about the
about project one and how we're going
about
identifying modifications the epi
transcript film
utilizing publicly available rna
sequencing data
so this is i i think maybe the second
time i've shown this
this table here maybe it's the first um
but
you have many of you if you've heard me
talk
you know that i like to utilize
publicly available data because it saves
money and there's a lot of information
that's stored in those data
because each of us within the community
is performed those
high sequencing experiments for a
specific reason
many of them many of those reasons are
an attempt to look at how plants are
responding to stress
so there's a lot of useful information
out there and we can process we can
examine all of this rna sequencing data
roughly 300
terabases of rna sequencing data
using this computational algorithm
hammer
that's brian gregory's lab developed
about seven years ago
and hammer is is capable of identifying
um 45 unique rna rna modifications
from rna sequencing data and it does
this
taking advantage of the way in which
i guess the pattern in which uh reverse
transcriptases
um interpret uh modified bases
so for reverse transcriptase that you're
using in your uh
rna-seq or cdna library preparation
comes across a modified base
that is that's modified along the watson
creek base bearing edge
it's going to see that modification and
it's going to it's going to think
that this specific modification is
actually or this base is actually
a different base than what it is and
it's going to uh
incorporate in the complementary
position a
the wrong nucleotide when you look at
this rna sequencing data
um when you align this rna sequencing
data this appears as a mismatch or a
snip
in your rna sequencing data and it's the
the frequency or the pattern
of mismatches that hammer is utilizing
after it screens for you know quality
score and and by allelic frequencies
it's this pattern of mismatches that
hammers is using
to infer a modification now just a a
real life example of what one of these
inferred modifications looks like
is if you have um so we have a uracil
here at this position we have a lot of
rna sequencing reads stacked up at the
site and we have
uh kind of a pattern of g's a's and c's
uh this uh frequency of which
uh hammer utilizes to infer that this
site is actually
um a modified uracil where a methyl
group has been bound to the
the third position
and of course all of this is based off
of training that
hammer has
training of trnas and other rnas that we
know
are heavily modified again
we we do all this identification but
we're not just identifying for the sake
of identifying we'd love to know
what these modifications are doing so
we're going through and
and performing very similar um
asking very similar questions to what we
were asking for the link rnas
we're asking questions about context
dependent deposition
so are each of these different marks
deposited in different regions
of the mrnas or of any of the link
kernels we're looking at
again each of these modifications we are
looking at each of these 45
modifications
we have very little knowledge or
understanding of where the marks are
deposited and what they're doing
so we would really like to know where
they're being deposited
and if these modifications are getting
applied during a specific developmental
time point or a specific stress
we also would like to know if we can
infer
biological roles for these modifications
based on the context under which they're
applied
do we see an increase in a modification
under a specific
stress experiment and do we see the
frequency or the levels of that
corresponding rna
go up or down um in those uh
those same contexts and then we would
also
like to know if these modifications are
conserved
we want to know if these modifications
occur on the same transcripts or
conditions across species
so that we can we can generate this uh
this rule book for what these
modifications are doing
across plants now the one
caveat or the one drawback of hammer is
that it can't
identify modifications that fall
outside of the watson creek base bearing
edge and unfortunately
m6a and m5c two of the the
well what we know are the two the more
common modifications
are outside of that watson quick space
base pairing edge so they don't actually
cause
errors during reverse transcription
so to identify these marks typically
what we have to do is we have to do
rna ips using an antibody for m6a
or we have to do bisulfite sequencing of
mrnas to get at m5c
these are incredibly tedious experiments
and
they typically under predicts
they they usually only recover about 20
percent
of modifications so to get at
to ask some more fine scale questions
about the roles of m6a and m5c in a
comparative framework
we're looking at um where we're looking
at these two modifications
uh within uh within brassy casey
and i'm just gonna reintroduce uh four
species i've already talked about
arabidopsis kimbelina brassica and
utrima
all close relatives are all relatives
within the nebraska casey and camelina
and utrima
just happen to be too uh heat and stress
taller or sorry heat and salt tolerant
uh representatives within the family um
and then in addition
camelina and brasica have undergone
recent relatively recent whole genome
duplication events
so now we have a comparative framework
under which we can ask a few different
questions that we can't quite ask
under such controlled conditions in our
hammer
project so the first question is is of
course
do species with differential stress
tolerances display unique patterns of
rna modifications
um and are the rna modifications
differentially deposited among paralogs
following whole genome duplication
do stress-responsive genes
there's a stress-responsive gene and
arabidopsis that's
for which we have orthologs and brassica
rapa we see differential modification
and potentially differential function
for those genes in brassica or camellina
and so this framework is allowing us to
compare really between species between
different genetic events
and between different stresses
and we're getting around some of the
technical difficulties
with rna immunoprecipitations
or bisulfite sequencing by performing
nanopore direct rna sequencing
now performing direct rna sequencing
means that we don't actually
convert the rna into cdna so we're
retaining all of the information that's
found
on that rna molecule i.e all the
the modifications that are found on that
rna molecule
and we're taking advantage of again
essentially of
base calling errors from the the
nanopore base calling
algorithm that can't quite interpret the
little squiggles the little
signal intensities that change when
it encounters a modified nucleotide
so just to remind you of what is kind of
happening
a very simplistic cartoon of what's
happening during menopause sequencing
of course we have these proteins that
are helping to
funnel an rna through a nanopore
and it's really this current that that's
coming across this membrane that changes
each time
a different base is read through as you
see here it's this current
that's being read and then being base
called and again
it's changes in the currents based on
the modification
that's telling us that something is
going on at this specific site
now we can't specifically say whether or
not
it's m6a or m5c unless we have
a a tissue or we have a
genetic background that is lacking or
knocked down from one of those
modifications
so we're using an arabidopsis a
methyltransferase mutant
mta mutants that's deficient for
m6a to train this epi nano
or tombow model and then we're hoping to
apply
this trained model to the other three
species that we're looking at
because we don't have genetic we don't
have mutants for any of the methyl
transferases
in camelina brassica rapa or eutrema
now we've performed the kind of systemic
heat and salt stress experiments and
we've collected the
or we've performed the nanopore direct
rna sequencing in each of these
species or genetic backgrounds and
we are currently in the process of
analyzing
these rna sequencing data for
modifications
so hopefully i'll have more to to talk
to you about soon
okay so i've told you now about uh
novel transcripts for which we we don't
really know much about and i've told you
about
uh the epi transcriptome which we know
is important but we don't know uh
completely what each of the different
marks are doing and lastly i'd like to
bring us back to
something we're all very familiar with
and we're all comfortable with and
that's
utilizing changes in rna abundance
to get out to understand mechanisms of
stress resilience and this work is
is uh really primarily a collaboration
with my cluster partner dr
magnukowska who's a i would say
a very uh excellent plant physiologist
and phenotyping expert
and she's going to be talking in a
couple of weeks so i'm not going to talk
about really any of the phenotyping or
the physiology
but what i would like to to talk about
are the different ways in which we can
utilize rna-seq
to to get at molecular mechanisms
of course rna-seq many of us have used
rna sequencing
in different levels of experimental
complexity
to get at our kind of candidate genes in
which were
that we then go in and target for
genetic assays or
etc and so of course the most simplest i
would say of experiments that
can be performed with rna sequencing are
of course the pairwise comparisons
between a couple of genotypes or a
couple of stresses
and then of course we can get a little
bit more complex and we can compare
between multiple
stresses or genotypes and really perform
something like
hierarchical clustering to get at a
specific subset of genes that are
enriched in a specific background that
we then
perform you know go enrichment or
something to make functional predictions
and then as i mentioned earlier we can
get even more complex and we can do
things like
expression networks uh to get at again
these modules of genes that are
that are enriched
under specific conditions and then of
course
there's what i would consider perhaps to
be the most experimentally complex which
would be associating
genomic association studies
with transcription or transcription-wide
analyses to identify genes
that are significantly associated with
uh specific phenotypes and just to give
a preview
uh we're looking at phenotypes and you
know obviously the brass casey
as well as solanaceae
looking at wild relatives of some of our
uh most favorite model systems
but um yeah what where did what's
like how are we going to go about i
guess uh how are we going to go about
getting to phenotype what are what are
the phenotypes that we're monitoring and
how are we doing this
um and again i'm not going to go too
much into phenotyping because that's not
my specialty
but my second hobby after rna biology is
computers
and what i'm showing you here is an
extremely small computer
the raspberry pi zero it's
i don't know if any of you still
remember the days of the iphone 4
many of you are maybe are looking at the
iphone 12 right now and
and salivating over it's the idea of
getting one
but this raspberry pi zero has similar
specs to
an iphone 4 so it's a very uh small
this is about this is sitting on a note
post-it note about three inches by three
inches so this is about an inch and a
half wide
and it's significantly cheaper than the
bank buster
iphone 4 at about ten dollars per
pi raspberry pi zero and we're setting
we're using these pies to control
cameras on these little flat phenotyping
rigs
where we are taking pictures we have two
cameras per rig
we're taking pictures every 30 minutes
um to monitor
changes and development of these plants
here you see them in the growth chamber
again
um we have right now we have nine of
these set up we envision
setting up um many of these rigs and
they again they allow us to
monitor plant growth over time
and just showing you here kind of
changes in the plants as they're
developing
these are pictures taken every 30
minutes and
what you get from this is or one of the
most
simple things you can get from this is
kind of change in pixel density over
time as the plants
are growing and you can compare this to
plants that have been stressed or
exposed to a specific stress
and you'll see that basically
we can use this high temporal resolution
phenotyping to identify uh
regions that are important or sorry
developmental tie points that are
important for
molecular analyses so this is helping us
to pinpoint when we should be
taking samples for rna sequencing and
then comparing it back
to the phenotypes that we observe that
magda is observing
i'll just wrap up to to in conclusion
say that i hope that i've exposed to you
or expose you to a few new aspects of
rna biology today
and helped you to appreciate the complex
ways in which
rnas can control mechanisms
of stress responsiveness both
influencing what's happening at the dna
level influencing what's happening at
the translational level
and also really what's happening at the
rna level
um so with that i i should stop and
thank a few people
um several people associated including
uh a magda associated with with what's
uh
i call the pulse cabanda the the polish
bandits
um this where where the the we've
branded ourselves the stress
architecture and rna biology lab um some
important people
that were associated with either the
link rna story or the transcriptive
epi transcriptomic story are listed here
um the new like third person in the
cluster
uh ola skurich working with her and with
magda
on an rna compartmentalization project
looking at stress granules
and of course i should thank you for
your time
and the nsf for funding thank you
and if there are any questions or if you
have any questions about my interests
and
adjunct ship with plant bio or with the
field
please fire away so just unmute yourself
if you'd like to ask
andrew a question or you can throw it
into the chat
i can do it go ahead for a second
so i don't like the term banda but my
question is
that's that's nag is doing i i i suppose
so yes
but my question is when you uh um
this concerns that non-coding rna
parts what do you think it's a is the
role of
the the secondary structure of those
uh link iron as if any so you you
that like you mentioned that that in
some cases there's just just the
the um
transcription complex assembly that's
what it's needed but do you think that
there is in in
i mean some of them has been shown that
they have secondary structure that's
important
i wonder like how prevalent this is you
think
i would argue that i mean i i hate
making like blanket statements uh
um about like a whole class of rnas but
um
i would say that structure is definitely
important for
um let's say a significant number
because obviously you need their um
so we've shown with with brian gregory
and and obviously
uh many others have shown that rna
structure is important for
the binding of rna some of these rna
binding proteins ancient rmps etc
and structure we think is important for
uh potentially important for recruitment
and to stress granules and um
yes so i think maybe you're getting at
uh like the degree to which we expect
structure to be conserved
is that uh you know that that would
actually be
the part of it yeah yeah so so
we don't have a a lot of information
about
structural conservation outside of a few
examples in plants but we do know
that there's there's definitely some
selective pressure on structure
being retained in vertebrate systems
where they have these like massive
genomic alignments and they can actually
look like get a good sense of the
evolutionary pressures there so um i do
think that structure is important for
some of these link rnas
but i don't have a good idea of how many
exactly thank you
so andrew that was a great talk and
thanks very much
um i have a question so some of the
covalent modifications of the rnas
you talked about and some of the
structures and potentially the small
orfs do they um have you noticed any
association with the potential
for um trafficking and flowing mobility
oh that's this is something i've i've
talked to
briefly about with margaret's um so
i know that a few of the link rnas that
we've identified
show up in a data set
produced several years ago now that was
looking at mobile rnas
um i don't know how i think this was
a mobile rna it's an arabidopsis and i
don't know
how you know i i would i
would need to look at that to see how
reproducible that was but but i do know
that
uh based on on again mammalian
literature that
modifications can be important for for
trafficking especially if like the
smaller
the the micro rnas um so i think that
would probably be where we would get
better traction in terms of you know
experimental evidence
i think it's relatively easier right
it's easier to look at
um you know with with markets crafting
experiments for instance to look at
trafficking of
micrornas than it would be and then to
get a sense of the modifications that
are occurring there
so that is definitely something i think
that
those modifications are important for
trafficking within the cell
and i wouldn't be surprised if they were
important for trafficking
between cells okay thanks
there's a question from adrian in the
chat
metamorph nanopore sequencing is known
for having non-random sequencing errors
do you think a high proportion of these
errors are really these types of
modifications
that is an excellent question that is um
that is something that the
authors so so there have been several
recent uh publications
on inferring modifications from
nanopore rna sequencing data and
of course nanopore would love you to to
think that all of those snips are a
result of modifications
um i don't think that's the case even
though they have improved their
sequencing
technology quite a bit there's still
some some random
errors but i think the the take home
from some of the more recent uh
publications uh
say um you know if
the error rates is like three or five
percent or something right now i think
you know a significant portion of those
can be attributed to
uh non-random like specific um
within the within the rna sequencing
it's specific
um errors that that
may be uh results of modifications not
just m6a and 5c
but some of the other
many other modifications so the
the group that was behind m6a
there was a recent arabidopsis paper and
there's a i think a 2019 paper in
mammalian
systems and there were a surprisingly
high number of m6a marks
in that they identified through nanopore
rna sequencing data
and they demonstrated that these marks
were specific they were m6a because they
had the the mutants to
do comparisons so i think nanopore is
going to be a really
strong resource for us
another question from jeff doyle in the
chat you mentioned polyprotein brassica
kca
could you elaborate on specific
questions you want to address about
your polyploidy yeah so i think one of
the
one of the interesting i mean i i have
no
i have no strong like a rationale like
for why i'm asking this question but i
think it would be interesting
if you know after uh whole genome
duplication events where you suddenly
have two genes i mean i
back up i think it would be interesting
if the ep transcription was somehow
involved in
sub or neo uh functionalization or
pseudogenization
particularly of stress responsive genes
again i have no
i think brian has seen some interesting
stuff in wheats where you have kind of
whole subgenomes experiencing
preferential modifications but
i i just i think it would be a
fascinating
aspect of of the ways in which genes
evolve
so great thanks
other questions anyone
um i'm curious about using hammer to
identify
the ptms and whether when you're using
like
data sets from multiple sources there's
a higher probability of misidentifying
um snips as modifications
yeah so the so some of the technical
details
um so we so we need
fairly deep rna sequencing um so i think
we need like within the transcriptome we
need you know
20x or so um so we're only really
confidently calling
um in the genes that are typically most
highly expressed
in addition we're not combining multiple
experiments into the same hammer
analysis per se we're
we're comparing between analyses so
let's say we have
tin uh leaf you know control i mean
everybody does arabidopsis or uses
arabidopsis seedlings for their
experiments so we have a lot of rna
sequencing associated with that
do we see across a
significant proportion of these
experiments the same genes getting
modified
in the same tissues under the same
conditions and then we compare that
between you know tissues or conditions
so cool any other questions
okay let's thank you andrew one more
time
thanks a lot andrew great talk thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu